are you are you empathizing with me it
must be hard i mean you've got so much
on your shoulders well you've got a talk
show podcast you're in a writer's room
you've got 18 kids listen a super busy
wife
you're out you appreciate that you
create all kinds of
you're a political flashpoint
you know uh often often attacked in the
media but hold on let's drinking you in
let's not lose sight of how hard it is
to be you oh rain i mean
a wash in royalty checks wow
knowing that at any
literally at any moment
in the day
somewhere in the world your face is on
television that's that's got to be hard
that's got to be
be difficult probably thousands of
televisions
hundreds of thousands uh yes yeah
screens i'm just saying
you're everywhere and it's gotta be
difficult you know you've got your own
zonkey i mean
it must be very difficult to own your
own half donkey half zebra karen feeding
of a zonkey is no joke it's not a joke
wow look at um that was amazing we were
really empathetic so empathetic i feel
like i was more empathetic than you but
still maybe a little more yeah i
empathize with that it must be hard
being so empathetic it is not easy but i
wonder
if out there there are any limits to
this empathy thing
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
okay so reza
have
are you an empathetic guy i mean are you
a compassionate guy i i guess i mean
like i want to think of myself in that
way but are you really though are you
really
in your heart connected
to
those
people we see every day the invisibles
the people we drive by the
people at the dry cleaners the guy
rolling the dumpster down the side of
the street
do you really have empathy for the other
no
i mean honestly no like
i can't tell you how many times this has
happened to me where i'll be like
walking down the street and i'll see
like a panhandler kind of sure and uh
coming i'm getting closer and closer to
him you're driving like a freeway off
ramp or something yeah yeah and uh and
you know i'll just the whole time be
thinking it's fine i'm just gonna ignore
this person and then of course i get
stopped at the red light right there
right there and i do what a lot of
people do right i just look out the
window suddenly there's something
fascinating
in the glove compartment i'm like
rearranging
my paperwork gotta check your emails
something else anything not to make eye
contact because eye contact means i
acknowledge you and now i have to do
something for you i salute the
you know funny thing happened to me the
other day this happened my son was in
the in the car and my my seven-year-old
basically was like hey dad
um
i think that guy needs some help
and of course like a good dad i was like
oh what guy that oh oh i
didn't even notice him had i noticed him
of course i would have empathized and
now of course i had to go and get a
dollar and give it to him just to be a
good dad
but no i mean the truth is is that my
empathy definitely has limits i i have
the ability to put like empathy blinders
on do you know what i mean like if i
don't if i don't see you if i don't
acknowledge you then i don't have to
necessarily
empathize with you i have empathy
when i've got time and space for empathy
but if i'm rushed if i'm impatient i got
someplace to go if i'm thinking about 20
different things i don't have time for
for no empathy but um there's a a study
from the stanford social neuroscience
laboratory that posits that there are
all these different aspects of modern
life that disconnect us
and disengage us
and all these
different forces at work kind of prevent
us from being empathetic
um or maybe one can say allow us to not
be empathetic yes allow us to not yeah
because we're in this culture of outrage
and anxiety
um and
uh we're in our little silos on our
social media um yeah all banding
together with the people that we 100
agree with and railing against the
others
so we see outsiders and people different
um as symbols of groups of people that
we fear and hate
that's a really interesting thing about
empathy right is that
uh it requires some kind of connectivity
some kind of connection like the person
has to you have to you have to find some
some something that you have a
relationship so here's a true story
here's a true story
the happiest person on earth
was a practicing buddhist
monk
in wisconsin
and they did an mri test on him
and they found the
literally the the happiest brain scan
they had ever found before where all the
happiness joy contentment centers were
lit up like a christmas tree and what he
was doing
is he was doing this buddhist meditation
on compassion
and
this buddhism i i actually learned about
this meditation and i teach it when i
teach young people
and i have them
practice it and you you start
really small and you go really big and
then you go really small again so you
start with like compassion for
you know a dog on the street and then
the people of a town and then the people
of a country and then you have
compassion for everyone on the whole
earth and then you bring it back down
and you have compassion for yourself and
it's a beautiful meditation to do and
this is the happiest person uh that
literally scientifically charted was
having maximum compassion for all seven
billion of us on the planet
so i guess what that means is that
if you
can
practice empathy if you can practice
compassion
to as many people as possible yeah
visible and invisible
visible is easy let's face it okay
it's the invisible people that's hard to
to you know practice compassion empathy
it's good for you yeah it actually there
is a benefit there's a payoff hmm
there's actually a payoff and this is
this is what always rankles me like
everything that we're taught in our
culture
um
and i always go off on this but i don't
care everything that our culture tries
to shove down our throats oh this will
make you happy stuff and status and sex
will make you happy but actually it's
always the opposite it's always service
to others and compassion for others and
those are things actually
scientifically psychologically and
spiritually have been proven for eons
uh will bring you the greatest
satisfaction and joy in your life well
then i guess the question is is why
don't we do it what keeps us from too
hard it's too [ __ ] hard it's hard
it's hard it's easier just to have
places to go man i gotta
you know my sunroof on my tesla's broken
i'm really i'm not kidding i gotta get
it taken care of and uh it's a pain in
the ass
[Music]
so we're gonna talk to someone who is an
expert on
so many things hard to describe what her
expertise is but certainly it has
something to do with getting us all to
care for one another a little bit more
deeply yeah and i would go one step
further and say
to care
specifically for those people that we
are primed to not notice yes right yes
right it's easy to care for people that
you notice exactly you've got people in
your family you've got your dogs your
neighbors yeah i want to help my
neighbor out i'm going to help those
people out sure no problem but if you're
invisible to me if i don't notice you
then i can just go to bed at night i
don't feel bad about it yeah you know
and what our guest does
is she
gets you to notice
the invisible people the people that you
that you ignore and
and this is i think the real miracle of
what she really does
is that
she gets you to care for them
she gets you to see them i jinpoo is a
lifelong activist and political
organizer she's the director of the
national domestic workers alliance
she is the co-founder of supermajority
which is organizing women across america
to get engaged in politics
author of the age of dignity
preparing for the elder boom
in a changing america
this is igen pooh
[Music]
i just um
helped to start a new women's
organization with alicia garza and
cecile richards and a group of really
badass women organizers
and we asked women who signed up and the
first month about a hundred thousand
women signed up in the first month
and there's a survey and we asked them
what their superpower was
and the number one answer was empathy
wow
you're working with um domestic workers
they're they're very poor in their
mostly they're unseen so
can we see this population better can we
get to know them better can we love them
better through empathy well this is
where i feel conflicted because i
actually feel so proud that
women said empathy was their superpower
and
i actually think it's an important value
and i have questions about its limits
because it still requires
a line between you and me
i still have to be separate in order to
feel empathy for you
whereas i feel like love to me
draws a circle around us both
and i wonder if there's
a
way that
the challenge is really about how we
expand the we
i mean the workforce that i represent is
a perfect example
the job of the women that i represent is
literally
to uphold the dignity of an older person
and
see their humanity and lift it up so
that they can have a dignified quality
of life as they get older or to nurture
the human potential in a child
these families are counting on
these women for the most important
aspects of their lives
presumably and so
it's all there all the natural
ingredients of interdependence clearly
love care it's all there and that's why
i've stayed in this field for so long is
because i actually think if we can
figure it out here where it seems like
everything is hitting so close to home
no pun intended
like really
it's a laboratory for understanding
humanity and it's all of its
complexities so that's something really
interesting that you said in there is
kind of the struggling with empathy
because you see empathy as something
that
separates us still it's like oh here i
am having this experience
i'm having this relatively positive
experience and though oh i see this
other person having a difficult struggle
and i'm
feeling for them and there's kind of
almost a pity that's involved and it's
me versus you and us having separate
experiences versus
love that connects us that
uh that brings us together that sees us
as one exactly mother teresa said if we
have no peace
it is because we have forgotten we
belong to each other that's right that
sense of belonging to each other is what
i feel like we need to get to and
empathy may be a first step
to
bring us into a different kind of
proximity to one another
to care but ultimately where we need to
get to is a sense of that oneness of
that sense of belonging to each other
and that is what i think we lack
so how do we how do we get there
well here's the problem rain yeah so
here's i mean
you know i feel like
there's this there's this uh thing that
we're kind of dancing around and not
really zeroing in on
because to talk about empathy and this
importance of like
understanding ourselves as belonging to
each other
is there is a racial component here
that that we can't argue so i'm really
really fascinated by sort of the the
neuroscience of of all this and the
craziest thing that i just learned was
that
the
the same part of our brain
that is essentially responsible for
empathy right the the part in our brain
that um allows us to experience uh
similar feelings as somebody who is uh
in pain or hurting or whatever how
empathy works the exact same part of the
brain that creates empathy
is also the part of the brain
that uh allows us to distinguish
ourselves from other people
so
here's the problem then
and there's been tons of evidence
about this
it now creates a situation and i can
understand why there's an evolutionary
reason for this sure um
in which
we show greater empathy
for people who look more like us
and less empathy for people who don't
there was actually this entire uh study
done where they found that people when
showed a photo of uh of a person um
making a particular like fearful face or
a pained face or whatever that
if that photo
was of the same race as the the viewer
it had a greater activation in in their
amygdala than if it was of a different
race and here we're talking about let's
be honest people who are primarily
uh from latin american countries right i
mean a lot of domestic workers uh uh
housekeepers
yeah they're women they're people of
color exactly
and it becomes that much easier to just
make them invisible
you know it's just yet another obstacle
to this whole notion of you know the key
is recognizing the oneness that we all
share well how do we do that when our
brains don't work that way
hey folks i just wanted to say that this
podcast is sponsored by better help is
there something interfering with your
joy your vitality betterhelp can assist
with your needs and match you with your
own license professional therapist you
can start communicating in under 48
hours and it's not a crisis line it's
not self-help this is professional
counseling and it's done securely online
there is a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide log into
your account anytime and send a message
to your counselor you get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
which can be awkward
hey it's that guy from the office he's
in this therapy waiting room oh he must
be pretty [ __ ] up better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available if you need it betterhelp
wants you to start living a happier life
today so visit betterhelp.com milkshake
that's better b-e-t-t-e-r help h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states now don't forget the special
offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners you can get 10 off your first
month if you go to betterhelp.com
milkshake take care of yourself people
milkshake listeners milkshake drinkers
maybe you want to eat something a little
more healthy than a milkshake well try
green chef do you see what i did there
green chef has a meal plan for every
healthy lifestyle it's got a keto a
paleo plant-powered diet
you know if you just want to have
delicious but balanced dishes green chef
is the way to go it's got expert chefs
and they curate every recipe with over
30 meal choices every week take homemade
plant-based meals to the next level with
green chefs plant-powered options i want
to watch your carb intake their keto and
paleo options will give you the premium
proteins and vital veggies you need to
conquer your day i have tried some of
these delightful
little
entrees and i'm telling you they will uh
spice up your week they're great what i
love about green chef is not only is the
food delicious
not only are the ingredients fresh not
only are the recipes new and unique my
kids loved the mediterranean stuff that
i got
but
the entire thing was recyclable
the ice packs
that it came in were recyclable and i
just i mean that was it man once i saw
that i was like i am a green chef
customer
for life so go to green chef dot com
slash milkshake 100 green chef dot com
slash milkshake 100 and use code
milkshake 100
to get a hundred dollars off including
free shipping that's incredible
that's green chef dot com slash
milkshake 100 and use the code milkshake
100 to get 100 off including free
shipping
green chef the number one meal kit for
eating well
well i think the other thing about
humans which is
um
which is unique to us as mammals i think
is that we
are able to make meaning um
make different kinds of meaning and
shift in our consciousness and even our
deeply held beliefs i mean if we think
about
the shift that this country has made on
how
the dominant cultural sentiment around
the freedom to love who you choose
right there was a set of deeply held
norms and beliefs that we had culturally
that was
that was
not acceptable not appropriate not okay
and now it is
the norm right it is and there are still
some people who think it's not okay but
as a culture we've shifted we've made
different meaning
and i think that one of the big
challenges we have right now is
that there's kind of a chaos of meaning
where you know there's one set of people
in this country who've been
basically fed one set of stories about
why they're suffering
why they're no jobs right they've been
told that it's the brown people it's the
immigrants it's the people of color who
are to blame
when we know it's not right but that's
the story
they had meaning makers who helped them
make that meaning
and it also means that we can help them
make different meanings so
what do we what do we do let's start
with the institution for for a moment
because i feel like that's weirdly
easier
than you know it's easier to change the
institution than it is to change the
individual
how do we how do we embed
empathy
in our
economy i think we look for ways of
changing our laws and our systems
to
really support
economic what i call economic dignity
right the the notion that
when we work
we should be able to provide for our
families
and we should be able to take pride in
what we do
because it actually does have value
we should be seen we should be
recognized and we should have
basic dignity afforded to us
and
there's a set of policies that would
really support that and invest in that
and
bringing people together around those
policies is incredibly unifying i've
been working on
strengthening our family care policies
for years
and the work of bringing families who
are really struggling to afford child
care and elder care together with the
workforce
that works incredibly hard but earns an
average of fifteen thousand dollars per
year for their work
together to say how do we
create systems that make care affordable
and accessible good care affordable and
accessible and really invests in our
caregivers in a new way
that i think you there's clear
ways to actually embed that
institutionally
caregivers have so much empathy for the
older people that they support who are
frail and really dependent on them
and a lot of the consumers of care are
elders people like my grandmother and
others
know that they would be lost without
their caregivers right there's a
complete sense of dependence
that could be a place where
a ton of empathy is cultivated for our
broader society i believe in the end
these values are majoritarian values but
sometimes we have to help people see
that and see the way forward besides
legislation which you're very involved
in you're talking about love uniting us
all
and empathy
you know connecting us on some
far deeper more profound level what what
do we do besides legislate to change the
attitudes in people's hearts
i think we have to do precisely that we
have to change culture and we have to
change the narrative our culture
is structured around a hierarchy of
human value
that values the lives and contributions
of people of color less than
those of white people
and
we have
a lot of truth-telling and unearthing to
do
culturally in this country
to
understand our history
to understand the human cost
of that hierarchy of human value
and in order to get to a place of
starting to change it
brian stevenson always says that
in truth and reconciliation it's
actually sequential that we have to have
truth
before we can have reconciliation
and we've never
as a country fully faced
the
history
and trajectory of racism in america
in a way that will allow us to never go
back
and to allow us to embody a different
way of being like deep in our in our
consciousness and our soul but i feel
like that story has been told it's been
told in textbooks and it's told
you know in the media and in movies but
to a certain set of people you know
generally racist white people you tell
them that story and they're like boo hoo
hoo okay they were slaves a long time
ago and civil rights was a long time ago
get over it stop playing the victim
and just get on with your lives i'm not
a racist my dad's not a racist we stop
complaining and can we just all move
forward and that story's
that story falls on deaf ears
i think that it is
how the story is told really matters
and that story is part of a story of
how we become a healthy multiracial
democracy
and
what is i mean right now the battle in
this country is a battle over the story
of who we are
who belongs
and who we can become
and
if
if we told the story in such a way
that really talks about
an
american identity that is
fundamentally pluralistic
where we can actually take pride in that
and
we have reason
to take pride in that and the pain that
we've been through
that we have to acknowledge
allows us to really leverage
the beauty and the dynamism of a
multiracial future
that's
i think the
that's the key
maybe
we're telling the wrong story yeah it it
maybe the story
is not about america's race problem but
about america's caste problem
you know i mean
it's so funny because like we can't like
in india like
cast like in india right yeah for the
people who are unfamiliar you know a
large part of
indian society very much you know um
tinged by um
its majority religion of hinduism is
predicated on this notion that
look there are just different uh casts
in society there are some people who
uh because you know past lives because
they just simply deserve it are rich and
wealthy and comfortable and visible and
there are people who are poor
and uh invisible and it's just how it is
and
that so much of that goes against the
very you know uh ethos of america right
we're a meritocracy [ __ ] um anyone
in this country can make it [ __ ] um
why don't we why don't we just admit it
which is a bit that's not true that we
have a caste system in america as well
uh
the the people who clean up after
the people who make the messes
and that's the story that we need to
start telling what i like about that
story is
the rate the caste system is about both
race and class
that it acknowledges
the economic
reality
the combination and the interdependence
of
racial
exclusion and economic exclusion
and that
feels really important to me in this
moment and
a huge part of why
this meaning making piece is important
because i do think that
there's a set of people white people in
this country who are really struggling
economically
like legitimately losing jobs
losing wages
um yeah they won't do they won't do the
office reboot
sorry i keep going this no that was a
really important point
um that's how we roll i jen here
metaphysical milkshake okay
this by the way is the most serious
we've ever been on a podcast so far
sorry i don't want to make us serious i
know some laughs that's important
i'm the comic relief okay let's let's
keep keep going yes so there's a there's
a whole strata of white people out there
that are really hurting
and they're afraid for their futures
they're afraid for their futures and
they're probably like this thing white
privilege that people are talking about
i really don't feel it i do not feel
privileged in this country they're in a
trailer park and they're coal mining
jobs taken away and a bunch of their
families hooked on opioids and they're
scared right and uh and really
struggling
100 and and
what they don't know that they need to
know
is their best allies and their power to
change
their
realities
is
locked up in a multiracial future right
they have to
their best allies are other working
class
black and brown people who are also
struggling and if we
made this economy and this democracy
worked for that multiracial majority of
working people in this country
so much would be different
do you ever get excited by a five-star
driver rating let's be honest ratings
matter a lot and when it comes to
finding health care ratings matter even
more zoc doc is an app where you compare
doctors by their ratings and read
reviews from real patients so you can
find and book highly rated local doctors
just download the free zocdoc app it's
the easiest way to find a great doctor
instantly you can book an appointment
with a doctor that's available to you
nearby with zocdoc you can search for
local doctors who take your insurance
read verified patient reviews and book
an appointment in person or video chat
never wait on hold with a receptionist
again whether you need a primary care
physician dentist dermatologist
psychiatrist eye doctor other specialist
zocdoc has got you covered every month
millions of people use zocdoc and i can
say with all honesty i am one of them
just a few weeks ago i needed to see a
doctor i needed to see it right away
i didn't know where to go what am i
going to do like google doctors around
me i honestly had no idea how to find a
doctor i went signed up found a doctor
near me made an appointment for the next
day which is like impossible to do went
to go see the doctor
it was fantastic zocdoc makes healthcare
easy now is the time to prioritize your
health go to zocdoc.com
milkshake
and download the zocdoc app to sign up
for free and book a top rated doctor
many are available as soon as today
show metaphysical milkshake some love
and use our code that's
dot com zocdoc.com
milkshake when your online checking
account balance is running low the last
thing you need is a 33 overdraft fee am
i right people i mean overdraft fees
have gotten way out of hand in 2019
traditional banks took 11 billion
dollars in overdraft fees now chime does
things a little differently chime is an
award-winning app and debit card that
has saved its members more than 10
billion dollars in overdraft fees with
spot me fee free overdraft eligible
members can overdraft up to 200 on debit
card purchases and cash withdrawals with
absolutely no fees you know one of our
life's big questions should be to
explore the
current
american capitalist financial
institutions
and systems
because it's pretty screwed up
i don't like to give banks all my money
this is a good idea chime check it out
you deserve to have financial peace of
mind join the millions of americans
already loving chime sign up only takes
two minutes and doesn't affect your
credit score get started today at chime
dot com slash milkshake that's chime
c-h-i-m-e dot com slash milkshake
banking services provided by and debit
card issued by the bancorp bank or
stride bank n a members fdic spot me
eligibility requirements apply overdraft
only applies to debit card purchases and
cash withdrawals limits start at twenty
dollars and may be increased up to two
hundred dollars by chime chime member
overdraft fee savings based on eligible
members use of spot me versus a 33
average overdraft fee overdraft fee data
based on bank rate checking account
survey and crl june 2020 overdraft fees
report
i got a question for you um i jan i mean
you're i mean so much of your work and
your life and your personality it just
oozes with
empathy but i wonder if you've ever in
your life have struggled to find empathy
for someone and
and what did you do i'll tell this one
story uh one of the first women i met
doing this work with domestic workers
was a nanny from jamaica named lily
and
she had been brought from jamaica by a
family from texas they were executives
in a
software company
and they brought her and they had
offered her mother that if she came to
be their nanny their living nanny to
help raise their children that she would
get access to a u.s education she could
go to high school in the united states
she would get a weekly salary that would
get sent home to her mother and so they
all thought it was a great opportunity
and she went to texas with them
and she ended up holding up her end of
the bargain she helped to raise their
children as a living nanny
but she was never allowed to go to
school
all communication with her family was
cut off so her family actually didn't
hear from her for 15 years
and she was never paid
for her time working there
she was essentially enslaved for 15
years
and she saw an article in the newspaper
tell me the family i'm going over there
right now with a pickaxe
who's the family i mean that's how i
felt when i heard about the story and
what's amazing there's so many amazing
dimensions of this story so
we end up helping her escape the
situation and the other person who
helped her escape was the child that she
helped to raise as a nanny who became
old enough to realize that what was
happening to his nanny was wrong
and he took the money from his piggy
bank to help her escape
and then she was able to connect to us
we found her a lawyer
and we had the conversation with her
about whether she wanted to press
criminal charges for being essentially
enslaved for 15 years
and she said
no she didn't want to press criminal
charges because she didn't want the
children to grow up without their
parents
that's incredibly generous so she then
so she had great empathy so she had
empathy for those kids who she
loved and cared for for 15 years
and i was like what
no way
and she you know we of course we filed a
civil lawsuit and we recovered some tiny
fraction of the wages in a settlement in
that case
i mean how do you repay
stealing 15 years from a person's life
right so i just was
angry and
couldn't unfathom but i learned so much
from
her incredible act of empathy towards
those children
that it's actually that it is possible
and maybe in fact necessary
for us to
both
have a deep sense of empathy and caring
and be able to seek justice at the same
time right that perhaps in our fight to
address injustice and inequality that we
have to both be clear and vigilant about
that and at the same time
never lose the thread of humanity and
empathy that's beautiful we're here
having this conversation uh about caring
for others and i'm remembering our very
first episode reza remember that way
back in the in the day
it feels like so long ago we were
talking about our life's biggest
questions and issues
your life's biggest question for however
many dozen people were listening to that
episode was
the thing that keeps you up at night is
the question of whether you're doing
enough for others
and caring enough for others
and you were positing it as like is it
enough for me to just care for my family
for instance how
how who am i responsible to what's my
tribe how how big does that tribe go do
i care for everyone around me but
um
so
how how would you answer reza's greatest
i mean look
i mean is that
it
is there a limit
to how much empathy
a person can have do you know what i
mean
i know that sounds weird yeah there's an
earthquake
burma there's a tidal wave and
you know north korea or like we have
empathy for all of these people that are
hurting what's my responsibility this is
yeah this is the thing that keeps me up
at night when i think like am i doing
enough am i
caring for
you know the the people around me
um yeah i mean
is there is there a limit to this i
think it's really great and important
that you're asking that question
um what's hard about this moment is that
we actually are living in a time of
existential crisis in our country
there are times
i think in the life of a country where
history moves faster than others
and it's times of massive transformation
which we're undergoing it's like the
1930s 20s and 30s right it's another
industrial revolution but you layer on
top of that demographic changes and
climate crisis and all the
all the change that we're hurt in the
middle of right now
and it just means that every single
thing that we do
there's so much at stake in our actions
and our inaction
and so
i will say that we have to find a
balance and not overextend our energy
and we have to ask more of ourselves
than maybe other generations have had to
in this country how do you how do you
maintain um
i don't want to say positive attitude
because that sounds ridiculous like who
gives a [ __ ] about a positive attitude
but i just mean like how do you maintain
optimism uh your commitment and your
commitment not even optimism because you
can be pessimistic and still and still
do good in the world but how do you just
resilience that's it that's the one i'm
looking for that's right how do you
maintain resilience
i love that word resilience um
i actually feel wake up feeling
so inspired and on purpose every day
because
two things one is the women that i work
with are so resilient i mean
literally the day after the election in
2016 when
everybody knew that immigrants were
going to be targeted in this
administration
literally undocumented immigrants in my
membership on the phone that night being
like what are we going to do what's the
next step what's the we're ready we're
ready to fight we're ready to go
and
the level of courage
and
um tenacity is just
endlessly inspiring and what i'm seeing
is people coming out of the woodwork
wanting to be on the right side of
history wanting to know what more they
can do i mean women in particular
have not just been
marching and running for office and
winning in unprecedented numbers they
want and they're not tired they want to
do more they want to organize they want
to win
they want to
they've been first responders and they
actually are on track
to help us take back the country and i'm
just seeing
the growing power
behind forces for good in this country
and it inspires me and as somebody who
is a professional activist like i also
feel really fortunate to
have a life that has
offered me the tools to know what to do
in a crisis like this there's a ton of
people who are like
oh my god another shooting another this
like what do we do and feel so lost and
hopeless and
i feel like i i actually know what we
should do and
and that
is a
tremendous amount of responsibility and
it's motivational
um and the thing about optimism that my
grandmother told me she's instilled
optimism in me from the time i was six
months old and what she said she's
somebody who's lived through war and
displacement and poverty and migration
and all the things
and she always said that
if all you see is darkness you can't see
the way forward
and
for me i'm like always looking for the
way
out of no way and light yeah you know
and i think that that optimism is is
actually really important for that
what we do with every guest is we have a
lightning round of life's big questions
some of our favorite
questions that keep us up at night
scratching our head so describe your
soul in 10 words or less
uh bright
and
uh porous
bright and porous
like it's like a
what do you hope happens after you die
oh that we everybody
has everything they need to care for
their families and care for the people
who care for us too what's one thing you
know for sure
that we will win and finally what is
your life's big question
how to make this country realize its
promise
beautiful
i jinpoo thank you so much for spending
time with us
this was incredibly thought provoking
and heart provoking
thank you for having me it was so fun
talking to you guys
[Music]
that was a that was pretty pretty
serious and sober
yeah episode that really affected my
heart
you know
here's the thing about
hanging out with ijen i mean i've known
her for a little while you spend five
minutes with her and you can't help but
feel better like feel more optimistic
feel more i feel better now than i did
before the conversation absolutely
started like i want to be a better
person yeah i want to reach out to
people more i want to see people more
and deeper right
well maybe you out there dear listener
have uh a similar story of either
finding empathy for somebody that you
didn't expect to or or losing empathy
for someone let us know let us know
about it
folks as you know we often end our shows
by asking you to rate and review us and
we tell you that if you put your life's
big question in that review who knows we
might have you come on the show and you
can ask us
that question and maybe we'll have an
answer for you maybe we can fix all of
your problems
we're not a self-help podcast reza jesse
valencia wrote a wonderful
uh review had a fascinating question for
us and here he is joining us now jesse
welcome to metaphysical milkshake hi
guys hi jesse i just want to say
your name is so awesome jesse valencia
is either like a hitman an action star
or a porn name what's your question
jesse is consciousness the result of
chemical accidents in material reality
or has material reality itself been
willed into existence by consciousness
oh jesse you're asking our favorite
question you know oh i love that one
you're clearly a fan of this show yeah
consciousness first of all let's define
terms a little bit and i think that reza
you could help with this um
because sometimes when people think
about consciousness they think about oh
my thought process right but if you dig
a little bit deeper our consciousness is
made up of not just our thought process
it's our perceptions and how that then
is triggered by a memory and then we're
humming a song slowly in our head and
then we're noticing something about our
body and we're shifting our body and we
look outside and see the sunset and that
changes our consciousness right but
that's not even the limit then you dig
deeper and consciousness is
that spark of aliveness
that drives us that is beyond
thought and beyond feeling because one
thing that we can do is step above our
thought process we can notice ourselves
thinking sometimes you notice like
you're in a worried anxious thinking and
you kind of go god i'm in a worried
anxious thinking why am i turning that
over and over in my head well that's a
consciousness that's greater than your
thought process so
it goes
when you start to dig into what
consciousness is it goes even deeper
than what i'm describing reza take it
yeah yeah no that's perfectly said i
mean i guess like the shorthand for it
is
awareness of the self right
um
you know descartes famously
uh put it this way right kogito ergosome
right i am thinking therefore i am so
it's like the knowledge that you are
perceiver
and thinker
um
and
you know as we've talked a lot about on
this show
it's a it's a massive mystery you know
what do they what do they call it rain
the big problem or the yeah the the hard
problem of consciousness yeah because we
just
we don't know how to to think about it
how to define it we don't know
where it comes from how it works or why
we have it reza like why do we have it
does how does it help us evolutionarily
to have
you know thoughts and feelings merging
with memories and perceptions and then
um on our hearts sores and then we sing
a song and write a poem how does that
help us survive i mean scientifically we
don't know how to map it philosophically
we don't know how to how to talk about
it and when you do talk about it
philosophically speaking [ __ ] gets weird
real fast i mean
oh absolutely the cart is a perfect
example of this descartes you know
started trying to figure out you know uh
consciousness and
ended up essentially accidentally
proving that nothing exists in the world
except the thinker
right that like i guess i'm the only
being that exists and you're all just
you know perceptions that my
consciousness has has created
but to your point
yeah look we're getting to the place now
where you know science and particularly
cognitive science is so
focused on being able to map every
experience every emotion right
everything that happens to us is just a
result of
complex electrochemical
you know um
interactions in the brain and so maybe
that's what consciousness is it's just
this kind of material
thing and as we've talked about on the
show before well then if that's the case
then you could if you can map
consciousness you know in the human
brain then can you recreate it in an
artificial brain sure yeah absolutely
then what does that mean about us as
human beings or is there anything that's
special about us anymore
those electrical processes and the
things that compose us how we are
is it that
those are things that are happening
inside of us or is there some sub level
of consciousness that has sort of willed
that into existence so that and that's
just the means
by which different beings are aware say
if you're a plant or if you're a human
being or if you're an animal or of some
sort is there
is it that
how we are aware of ourselves is that a
chemical accident well it would be if
you just subscribe to
materialist perspectives you know of of
reality but
i think there's a deeper level where you
know you know a lot of things about like
vedanta or i'm probably mispronouncing
that completely
philosophy or vedic philosophy that
drives like the gm movement or something
like that you know coming from that
perspective it would be that there is
like this super soul kind of residing
under everything and everything else
kind of vibrates upwards from it
so i was just curious to hear what your
guys's uh
ideas behind that might be considering
your different backgrounds and
traditions it's such a great question i
don't have any answers around this
obviously but when i think about god
again we defined terms around
consciousness when i think about god
um
so often people who say they don't
believe in god have a very different
definition of those who do believe in
god
if i believe that the
the universe
and by the universe i mean the
multiplicity of universes by infinite
universes folding one on top of another
and within each other and without each
other that there is a consciousness
pervading all of these universes
then this consciousness would birth
vis-a-vis uh
you know material tools i.e you know a
cerebral cortex and neurons and
chemicals and whatnot would create
consciousness
as a mirror of this universal
consciousness so each of our tiny
consciousnesses
i don't know that we make up the
universal consciousness but we certainly
reflect the universal consciousness so i
think there's a dance between the
physical and the spiritual and it goes
back and forth it's like rumi said the
ocean in a drop right that's right i
like to sometimes just replace
consciousness with the word soul because
they're they kind of mean the same thing
for me i know that soul tends to be
spiritualized
and consciousness you know perhaps is a
little bit more
scientific in the way that we think
about it but
if you think about consciousness as
awareness of self and if you believe as
i believe and as reign believes that
that the self like who we are
at our core
is eternal right
then you can think of consciousness as
being synonymous with soul
um
and so
it to me that kind of transforms it
gives it gives the concept of
consciousness the spiritual weight that
i think it deserves
um and and it takes it away a little bit
from kind of what you're saying jesse
this idea of thinking about it solely as
a product of material
you know
elements right now i'm not saying that
they can't be both you know we
we we do not subscribe to those simple
you know substance dualism ideas that
that you know uh if if the soul is a
real thing then it is part of the
material experience you don't have to
sort of divorce it from the material
world but nevertheless i do think that
thinking about it in those terms
kind of shifts the way that you consider
the meaning and the power
of what what consciousness truly is and
what role it plays in the human
condition
absolutely
you blew our minds jesse you blew my
mind you blow my mind every week i love
this show
jesse valencia if that is your real name
thank you so much for joining us on
metaphysical milkshake thank you guys
hit us up on twitter guys at meta milk
podcast
reza aslan rayne wilson
metaphysical
talk to us about
deepening compassion do you have any
tips do you have any questions related
to this issue
how can we
bring visibility to the invisible
thank you again to our incredible guest
today igenpoo
and listeners
we'll catch you next week with another
incredible guest and another amazing
mind-bending episode of metaphysical
milkshake
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold an audio mixed by justin
kyle original music by jeff tang it was
additionally executive produced by goal
reese lucina and daryush brazwella no
thaft it was produced by amy estroy and
rebecca lehrer of the mashup americans
associate producers are jocelyn gonzalez
lindsey crowderwill sarah pellegrini
mary phillips sandy and shelby sandlin
here's another thing that you should
know about igen is that
she is a macarthur genius uh fellow
she's like literally a genius and while
you know that's
nice how do you apply for that well
that's exactly that's what i was gonna
say is like
i feel like i'm not dumb i mean what's
up macarthur people it's not hard to my
email is easy to find is it do you go to
like macarthur genius.com and fill out a
survey or something like that how do you
get that i don't know
i don't feel like they'd ever give it to
character actors like oh
oh the guy who played dwight he's not
that guy's definitely a genius
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you